Salut, aujourd'hui je vais pas faire cette vidéo
non je vais plutôt la faire demain.
Mais demain j'en ai déjà une
Je la ferai l'année prochaine
Ce matin, je me suis réveillé
Je vous avoue, j'avais la flemme de faire cette vidéo
Mais vraiment, j'aurais tellement aimé
pouvoir reporter ce moment
J'avais envie de
PROCRASTINER
Procrasti-quoi?
C'est un mot un petit peu rigolo qui veut dire
remettre au lendemain
repousser un petit peu le moment
C'est se mettre devant l'ordinateur pour travailler
et s'apercevoir au bout d'une demi-heure
qu'on est sur Facebook en fait
On actualise la timeline
Heureusement j'ai des astuces pour vous empecher de procrastiner
et pouvoir vous améliorer et vous auto motiver
C'est d'ailleurs une des demandes que vous aviez faites durant le live sur Périscope
C'est Cyril qui avait demandé
Première étape : il faut être organisé dans sa tête
et sur le papier. Je vous présente donc
le super héros, celui qui prend
la procrastination
qui la tord et qui la jette,
la TO DO LIST ! Faire une to do list c'est un
très bon moyen pour identifier tout ce qu'on a à faire et pouvoir s'organiser
, le poser sur le papier et identifier
les choses qui sont urgentes, qui sont à faire,
qui sont reportables ou pas. Je suis un amoureux
des to do listes. Si vous voulez faire comme moi vous prenez des fiches
Bristol, j'en ai des jaunes
j'en ai des bleues... des roses, des vertes...
Quand vous écrivez votre to do liste pour qu'elle soit encore
plus motivante , vous pouvez la sous-catégoriser
Si je dois faire les courses, je vais pas écrire "Faire les courses"
trop compliqué, je sais que je vais le repousser.
Dans ma to do liste je vais marquer : faire une liste de course,
aller au magasin, faire les courses,
ranger les courses. A chaque fois que je vais réaliser une des
étapes, je vais pouvoir la barrer. A chaque fois que vous
barrez une étape, vous libérez un petit
stock d'endorphine, que vous avez quand vous mangez
du chocolat; quand vous faites du sport, quand vous avez un orgasme,
quand vous avez un like sur Facebook
SI, y'a des études qui ont été faites là dessus...
La to do liste, c'est important, c'est essentiel, faut la faire.
Pour être efficace et ne pas procrastiner, il faut
aussi savoir dire non, NON, NON!!
Il faut savoir refuser certains projets
certaines choses que vous n'avez pas envie de faire, il
faut savoir dire non, ça c'est.. non, j'ai pas envie de le faire
Pourquoi? Parce que si vous dites oui par gentillesse
vous n'allez jamais le faire. Ca va faire naître en vous
un sentiment de culpabilité
Vous allez vous sentir coupable de ne pas faire ce truc
sur lequel vous vous êtes engagé mais que de toute manière
depuis le départ vous n'aviez pas envie de faire. Les amis,
je vous le dis, sachez dire non. Obligez-vous
à bloquer 2h par semaine pour travailler
sur quelque chose qui vous fait vraiment plaisir
qui vous fait vraiment envie. Vous le reconnaitrez facilement, c'est le truc
dont vous parlez depuis 2 ou 3 ans et vous dites
"non, mais UN JOUR je vais faire ça, j'prendrai un moment
et ça c'est sûr, j'vais le faire.
J'vais travailler un peu la dessus, c'est sûr.. dans 1000 ans
à peu près, mais je...le... ferai"
Le seul moyen de réaliser ce projet, ce truc qui vous tient à coeur
... dans l'coeur!
C'est de vous obliger à bloquer
2h dans votre semaine pour ça.
Et vous allez pouvoir prendre un moment là dessus
et ça vous fera du bien à la tête
et ça vous fera du bien à l'âme
D'autres astuces en vrai quand vous devez travailler sur quelque chose qui n'est pas en lien
avec Internet, l'ordinateur ou le téléphone, coupez
le wifi: vous ne serez pas tenté d'aller geeker durant des heures
pour rien, et je peux vous dire que je parle en connaissance de causes
Offrez vous des récompenses
et ne faites pas l'inverse; l'inverse ça fait culpabiliser
Par exemple, si je dois faire qqch, si je dois faire
un SUPER tableau Excel sur mon ordinateur
hahaaa!
Ca marche pas sur moi parce que j'aime bien faire ça en vrai..
On commence à se dire dans ces moments là
"Allez, je prends un café, je fais une petite
pause de 5 minutes et je m'y mets!"
Et quand vous avez fini votre pause et votre café
et que vous n'avez toujours pas envie de vous y mettre, vous culpabilisez
C'est un sentiment désagréable. Malheureusement,
c'est normal. Alors que si vous faites l'inverse, si vous vous
octroyez des récompenses, vous aurez le bon sentiment
en vous, celui de la réussite et de l'accomplissement
Il suffit juste d'inverser. Quand
j'aurai fait ça, je me ferai une pause de 5-10 minutes
je me prendrai un café . Et suivant la tâche à
accomplir, offrez vous des récompenses plus ou moins importantes
Voila quelques astuces qui j'espère
vous empêcherons de procrastiner en tout cas
vous aiderons à ne plus procrastiner
Et surtout vous déculpabiliseront. MERCI
à tout ceux qui contribuent aux sous titres de ces vidéos (de rien, avec plaisir! :p)
Ca fait longtemps que je vous ai pas remerciés, merci, merci MERCI!
MERCI beaucoup!!
Si vous êtes intéressé, il suffit juste de contribuer aux sous titres des vidéos
qui sont passées. En faisant ça, on peut créer de nouveaux sous titres,
on peut corriger les fautes des sous titres
qui sont déjà en place. Ca permet qqch de juste
exceptionnel: ça permet de rendre toutes les vidéos
accessibles aux malentendants. Merci encore
à tous ceux qui prennent du temps pour le faire. Si vous vous êtes parfois
reconnus dans cette vidéo..." je me mets encore UNE vidéo
et LA ce coup-ci je m'y mets!" Faîtes le moi
savoir en mettant un petit POUCE EN L'AIR
N'oubliez pas de commenter, je lis tous vos commentaires
Vous pouvez aussi vous abonner. RDV demain à 17h pour le prochain
mental vlog, CIAO!! :)
ciao, ciao, ciao ou peut être à bientôt, je suis
jeudi, vendredi et samedi en spectacle à l'entrepot théâtre,
si vous voulez venir c'est cool et peut être on fera
une vidéo après! ;)